on October the 4th 1957 the first
satellite Sputnik 1 was launched into
space
evil evil allowed a beautiful exhibit II
although it burned up in the atmosphere
three months later many satellites
launched since then have not leaving us
with a virtual junkyard orbiting the
Earth
now those debris represent a real threat
to the television communications and GPS
satellites not to mention the astronauts
but luckily the Swiss have a plan to
clean up space so I've come to Los an to
figure out how they're going to do it
most of the space junk orbiting Earth is
within 2,000 kilometers of the Earth's
surface there are over 22 thousand
objects larger than this soft ball and
over half a million larger than this
marble now all of the orbiting debris is
going about seven to eight kilometers
per second but since the objects are
moving relative to one another the
average speed of a collision is about 10
kilometers per second and an object this
size going 10 kilometers per second has
about the same impact as a midsize car
going nearly 200 kilometers per hour
that's enough force to destroy any
satellite in orbit as a veteran of four
space flights Swiss astronaut claude
nicollier knows the dangers firsthand
all of the large debris are tracked by
radar we know their orbit exactly and
sometimes we had to do the small change
in the orbital characteristics of our
spaceship the Space Shuttle Space
Shuttle Endeavor because it is foreseen
that that next day or two days later
we're going to have a close approach
with a with the debris such that NASA
was not feeling too good about that and
we changed late our orbit so to make
that distance limit larger fortunately
to date there haven't been any serious
collisions with manned spacecraft but in
2009 a single crash between two
satellites
added a whopping 2,000 new pieces of
debris if we don't do anything space
would become soon inaccessible because
of the large amount of debris and the
high risk of condition so the Swiss
determined to do something about the
problem are extending their clean
country reputation into outer space
a Swiss space center has launched a
program called clean space one that is a
demonstrator of a capability to remove
debris and the idea is to go and remove
one of two satellites from Switzerland
one of these two satellites is
appropriately named Swiss cube Swiss
cube is a small satellite which you see
this is a one-to-one model so this is
the in the right scale it belongs to
Switzerland so we had to do something
about this you can't have Swiss junk
just floating around in space no that's
not acceptable so the mission for clean
space 1 is a proof-of-concept that a
janitor satellite can be sent into space
to grab a piece of space junk in this
case Swiss cube and bring it back into
the atmosphere where it'll burn up but
to rendezvous with the space junk the
small janitor needs an incredibly
efficient engine working on the
challenge is professor Herbert Shea an
expert in micro mechanics this is your
purpose is a foot washing system little
silicon micro machine shops we use
something called electric propulsion
which allows you to emit single atoms
with a that are electrically charged and
you use an electric field to accelerate
them out so you're not bring them you're
emitting your propellant and that's what
many small satellites use but nothing
has been to date been able to make
something this small so we do 0 to 60
miles an hour in about three days
but laughable as it indeed seems all of
us because there's no friction in space
or negligible friction then if we wait
six months we have a huge change in
speed and that's how the mission will be
done
once propelled into the correct orbit
the next challenge is to grab the space
junk an object tumbling around
uncontrollably without creating more
debris our idea is to use a very
compliant system can I think of an
octopus arm an octopus arm is very soft
but it can grab any strange shape and
wrap around it and hold it and we'll
have a grabber that looks in a very that
the real one will be more sophisticated
but looks like this so it's basically
very very soft elastomer I'll turn it on
in a minute you can see how how soft is
and the idea is this will be rolled up
so it doesn't take a much room you get
in to spend we'll have ten of these in a
series get into space you unroll it and
then these things can open when you turn
a voltage on you're able to open this
and you turn the voltage off and it
wraps around and it holds the satellite
is this gonna be a little bit like those
games where you're trying to pick up a
stuffed toy on the arcade and drop it
somewhere is it gonna be like that
essentially yes those games those games
can be incredibly frustrating with these
little arms they're built of you
frustrating where is this this is built
to be this is built to succeed
can I ask has anyone ever successfully
gone up and grabbed a piece of space
chunk and gotten rid of it to my
knowledge no it's never been done before
uh I think grabs on ambitious as it may
sound the Swiss know how vast this
junkyard is so their ultimate aims are
more modest hopefully studying in say
2020 to do a systematic removal of the
large debris at the rate of 5 or more
per year
in order to contain the increase of the
debris density low-earth orbit then
space will continue becoming accessible
because the exposure to the space
environment is a wonderful thing all the
way from strophic to see it for myself
welcome to Alaska just outside of
Fairbanks and I'm trying to find the
Northern Lights the borealis